an investigator investigates he goes
who's to benefit like there is no
benefit for Muslims there's no benefit
for Aslam what are you guys thoughts on
this and it's interesting that you know
the tiny Christian community and tiny
Muslim community in sri lanka that
really didn't have any problems in the
past all of a sudden you know like why
are they fighting there's like there was
no tensions between them you know they
were they were having a good
relationship it seems like someone wants
now you know these agendas to have
Christians and Muslims fighting and this
is what I like about your film that
[Music]
so I'm like oh how you guys doing I'm
with the director of the hit documentary
freedom and to his right in the left the
two white Muslims how you guys doing I
saw a lake home it's really nice last
time we were all together in Manchester
with you brother you just came out
[Music]
[Music]
fantastic people were happy to know
where the Sun is a wonderful religion
and some people for the people that
don't know who are tuning in and maybe
they weren't up to speed about what had
happened in Christchurch can you kind of
give us a history of like what had had
facilitated you actually being there
this attack that happened on a house of
worship in Christchurch New Zealand
[Music]
[Music]
to understand we was injured and I was
so like these people they've suffered
something and just three days after we
can pick her people like us for the
street
what spirits and 27 which is a feeder
day in South African and Prince William
of UK and France were we were people and
they came to talk to the family and and
fantastic
[Music]
chef of the machinery with spectres that
actually there's no such a thing as
really the problem among religions is
more about the devil the whole forces
are actually beyond all these axes and
instead of blaming the jewels the
Christian must see me we have to start
to blend really responsible beyond
distraction
and it was from the scholar and and
people is to wake up you know this crazy
murderer who I will call terrorist
committed an act of terror by going into
a lot with an automatic rifle and
indiscriminately shooting people so this
was a crowded mosque he murdered many
people including sister's children and
brothers prayed tomorrow
this act of terror this is what happened
in crisis happened in too much news on
the sender in Christchurch and this has
been globally there's been a global
outcry against this should never happen
the people of Christchurch people in New
Zealand have been overwhelmingly
supportive of the Muslim community and
support of the media labeling this
monster as a terrorist to Morton News
and I don't quite have changed little
licks in that respect so the vibe now
that you are getting you had a lot of
people that were very interested now the
sad and tragic event that happened there
in Christchurch New Zealand you you you
wonder we send our again our condolences
and our prayers for the families who are
affected by this and you were you got to
meet a lot of the family members there
and and how was there how was your
interaction with them
I bet the brother of the stabber for
example they were so strong I mean I
would have lose my favorable
circumstances I don't know but these
people ready
you know dr. earth and the life goes on
in a great spirit so I think it was so
so strong and we know that our notches
at the end of the day if you look at
history it's just happening and we know
in the mansion so from a spiritual
perspective I think difficult for
everybody but I think even stronger now
it's very strong will never be the same
but I think for the better and enormous
another huge opportunity to to look at
and a different angle and benefits you
know for me stamina and understand the
wisdom youngest region and the truth we
got to see pictures we got to see many
women standing in solidarity they were
wearing the hijab we heard a lot of
rumors how how true are they that there
was a lot of people that now who were
showing solidarity but then they started
to look into Islam and you know like you
like you brothers there all three of you
actually you did the same thing you guys
looked into Islam you look at the
evidence that are provided and you guys
concluded you know now based on emotion
but on intelligence on proof and
evidence that Islam was indeed the way
of life from the Creator and then is
that true that many people in
Christchurch New Zealand they actually
they also many have started to accept
Islam is that true Russia the
reimbursement money for this and
very happy to watch the vehicles it's
very inspiring for you to see 50
commerce in 25 countries and feel a lot
anymore so so much alike it's a great
beginning and this is very me to
conferences rights a lot a fresh human
rights is to worship Allah problem the
way he wants us to worship this is we
always talk about human rights but as a
human being you first human rights to
worship allah god's rights and i think
that talking about and and we met some
at least we we met also evil people from
mexico for me and how would you brothers
put that in perspective for someone who
just for the first time they've been so
disconnected from their fit that or from
their natural way that now they're being
reminded and when people for the first
time may hear such words as worship
you know allah you know these things you
know they they have a hard time
processing this how do you put it put
this down in a perspective that people
can connect when you because you guys
come also from from from your past that
this was also quite foreign to you so
you're hearing this you know it's it's
God Almighty's right to be worshipped
how do you guys put this in a
perspective now that maybe somebody
who's went far disconnected from that
they can connect with hearing this for
the first time
the names of their friends tragedy that
should never happen however it did and
around us community that reacted in a
way that was actually quite surprising
and pleasantly surprising you're right
sisters came out women who are Muslim
decided to wear the hijab in almost in
sympathy and coming out all we saw was
newscasters newscaster was wearing hijab
not where the job is and just that's
amazing isn't it because for the common
mantra that's pushed out there that
Islam oppresses women now these women
who are not Muslim why would they be
putting a symbol of oppression on them
if they felt that same thing doesn't
make sense liberating is clearly true
that's true liberation do you think you
guys do you do you guys think if this
terrorist would have had a chance before
he did this terrorist acts of killing I
believe it was fifty innocent human
beings if he would have saw this film
freedom how many what you say so it's
fifty one innocent human beings
including men women and children
innocent human beings if this terrorist
would have before he did this crime this
terrorist act if he would what do you
think if he would had a chance to watch
this film freedom you think that this
would have had an impact on him
[Music]
[Music]
if you know religion where some people I
think actually your son's recognize
people that look like that that are like
you are saying these words actions
the new person will do circumference its
pre-registration www dot and then you
conference calm and and we can worship
from the Prophet on the whole especially
we decide about you and your people in
the US because we haven't done spinning
there so it's gonna start like 8 a.m. in
the morning anytime and then the
screening of the free content from some
of the best tell us aw we're gonna go
ahead and come back to that very
important film and very important
conference is coming up that's this
month on the 11th correct and that's at
what and the website again is what's the
website that they can go and register
now we're gonna remind them we're gonna
remind them again but now something else
I wanted to ask you guys another sad and
tragic event just happen also and what
do you guys thoughts on that I would
just be older I could not imagine again
it seems like it doesn't make sense
because I mean obviously again you guys
open open minded individuals who
investigated Islam and you see what it
promoted peace love happiness
I mean peace love justice you know now
you have this this tragic event also
that happened in Sri Lanka it doesn't
make sense like what are your guys
thoughts on that obviously from the
Islamic perspective this there's no
sanction for it in Islam so then they
usually ask like look when an
investigator investigates he goes who's
to benefit like
there is no benefit for Muslims there's
on this human beings do fundamentals not
effects
it's you know unfortunately is being
juiced by the action of certain
individuals and what really should
happen is that those individuals should
be judged by the tenets of Islam
you know the media of things on their
head look at things the wrong way up you
know what's what happens and these
people that do these accordant acts you
know I'm going to put my my neck over
block here and say that in my opinion
that person at the the very point at
which that person detonated a device
that went and killed or maimed innocent
people at moments you have abandoned
these are the boundaries at that time so
no no way is any of these actions in any
way associated with the tenets of this
beautiful are we going to say Oh Doron
by those people you know something we'll
just say whatever she says you know this
is doesn't mix and applause to be a bit
smarter and when any groups claim some
attacks where's the proof I mean and
then so because it's obvious so that's
valid
no this is not how we see things now
[Music]
[Music]
Julian is one interesting thing Robert
Pape you know he was a terrorist expert
an academic here in Chicago actually he
talked about this where suicide bombing
originated from the time'll Tigers back
there when the Hindus were fighting with
the with the with the Buddhists and it's
interesting that you know the tiny
Christian community and tiny Muslim
community in sri lanka that really
didn't have any problems in the past all
of a sudden you know like why are they
fighting there's like there was no
tensions between them you know they were
they were having a good relationship it
seemed like someone wants now you know
these agendas to have Christians and
Muslims fighting and this is what I like
about your film that it helps to bring
you know humanity together and these are
the positive things that we need to push
but this is very interesting one point
is that Islam is free of this there's no
benefit for Muslims or Islam in this and
then the second thing is keep your brain
on you know don't let all this thing for
you and don't just swallow what you're
fed hold
[Music]
[Music]
so we have to but because this is just
[Music]
propaganda yen is appropriate this is it
this is good
go ahead Yousef what were you saying
yeah what we have to be mindful of
always rudeness is heinous things do
happen these these crimes do take place
but how anybody can relate what happens
back to Islam is beyond me
compassionate merciful you know and
that's it we have a compassionate and
merciful God Allah and merciful God that
just doesn't make any sense at all so in
no is any of these heinous crimes
committed in in the name of the religion
religion practice yeah that's a profit
point you know you guys wouldn't be part
of something that was calling for
oppression of people that was calling
for a destruction of humanity like you
know many
the hate provocateurs try to push out
there and many ignorant people they bite
on that people who are just naive and
people who don't research and really
don't put their their mind to work
because people have stopped reading
people have stopped you know
investigating the thing is that's it's
ironic that you see now you know you got
Muslim women you got Muslims being
persecuted there where this happened
because people are taking revenge on
them so again no interest in Islam no
interest or Muslim and actually this is
bringing so much more harm to the
Muslims in that community now it's just
sad for the Christians sad for the
Muslims and you know we need films like
this like freedom people who correct
information that's out there that's
going to help perpetuate perpetuate some
goodness like this media freedom you
know reflect yes commonalities but this
is what for decades you know and it's
not really stopping actually increasing
so we should continuity to allow people
to understand better and for not even
the ones were searching but everybody
basic understanding what is the some
about what are you guys what do you what
do you guys think of the sad I just had
this has just been on my mind also you
just cannot believe you know what's
going on today you have a modern day a
Holocaust that's happening in
Inquisition a modern day Inquisition
happening in China what do you guys
thoughts on this you guys know much
about it you have almost three three
million almost three million Muslims and
the world sleeps there in concentration
camps women are being forced to marry
you know they talk about forced
marriages they attack Islam but
everything that these hey provocateurs
they're out there
lying about Islam right under the
world's eyes where the world sleeps this
is happening and nobody's saying nothing
yet they don't have to stop because
[Music]
that's why again this film like this
freedom is so important projects like
this that promote education
understandings and to counter this false
narrative that's perpetuated that
creates Muslims as the other Islam is
something that's the boogeyman coming to
get you
so freedom free or money
Muslims in history you sub spread for
the large portion of China and the
Chinese they believe in worshipping
their ancestors or you know they believe
in respecting ancestors big time so
what's happening now the Chinese are
realized by attacking the massive
Chinese they actually be training Varane
ancestors so this is grave
this is massively great because a large
portion of China used to be Muslim is
still a part of it but actually most of
the Chinese who's maybe the grandfather
great-grandfather actually Muslims so
it's actually or even on a spiritual
level based on the faith we would use to
respect higher ancestor Wow how can you
respect us Esther if you're butchering
the people who are following the faith
of your ancestors so what's happening
because people lost grasp of history
they don't know anymore where we come
from well I know for example you know so
when I'm going to use it
I told because most of the Kiwis are
like me so I'm not that different from
you guys
Manuel Manuel my mother is some students
from class do so because I know a bit of
my history I could connect in the
Chinese of Beijing Shanghai if they
really knew who were their ancestors
they would be outraged yeah
where where are the fat worth if I say
we're the feminists the women to stand
up for women's rights for these women
that are being oppressed in China where
the junk the George Clooney's you know
they like to step up and now when the
celebrities the people of the world to
come up and to tweet send the tweet send
a Facebook post shares something you
know that to educate people on what's
going on so more people can speak up
though so the world can be outraged so
God willing this this Holocaust
modern-day 2019 Inquisition that's
happening against innocent human beings
can stop
can't expect enormous into again to do
the job for ya first of all the Muslim
Ummah is not outraged the Muslim Ummah
will just tweeting let to be outrageous
to do much more to do film is to do
demonstration in front of embassies put
pressure on most issues and so because
they don't like but yeah yeah something
that doesn't care you see the difference
between the Chinese and the West the
West doesn't care anymore back here is
longtime Gong but the Chinese is
something they really appreciate you
know so the thing is demonstration will
be a powerful thing but again as the
Muslim we need to go out of the way
sacrifice time to make the right move
and there's no leader in in the right
now and this is probably is why we're
lacking unity but we are lacking either
XI because nobody is calling the shots
do you know and until some strong
leaders we need some Malcolm X to come
back in our in our D not really with
hundreds of them to speak the truth to
the tyrants of this world because this
is part of many people are listening to
us today they are probably reading the
Quran and they will realize that the
story of Musa always comebacks again
what does it tell us
Musa was the Prophet that stood up
against tyranny yeah and that's what a
star wants from us that's what this
story always come back is to inspire us
to not accept injustice it's very simple
if Sam is against every form of
industries the towards Muslim and
non-muslim as well yeah therefore when
great interest is in the normal world we
also must stand up you know and this is
the thing we're not good at we have to
you know what people will stand
for us when we're not standing up for
industries are happening all over the
world so that's what we are based here
on earth we are preoccupied with
everything but is it just for the human
world and the animal world the
environment world it just is happening
to the animals we must see that now
yeah I often think the chickens can't
even get peace I mean the animals out
there can't even get peace with all this
all are all do the cruelty that's
happening tell us you guys just being on
this platform together you know these
beautiful lovely faces are dispelling
great myths of injustice of islam is
just something for the arab I mean you
guys come in from Christian Catholic
secular backgrounds I mean you name it
you guys have experimented with it but
now you're actually you're your ones who
have submitted to the will of the
creator and that's what simply a Muslim
is what it means to be a Muslim and you
guys are there on stage together I'm
talking to all of you so that's just
powerful in and of itself me amazing
seeing all of you guys together and one
one thing I just came from from the
heart of Europe in Bosnia and talking to
learning more of the history there and
there was a beautiful point of history
that I'm enjoying sharing I thought I
was share with you guys and and and the
viewers that one of the largest nation
because you guys also come from back
from a Christian background the Bosnians
there they were in between you know a
conflict where they had the Trinitarians
and and people who they didn't agree
they agreed more with what the fitna
with worshipping the crater alone at the
creation Jesus being a messenger sent by
God and they were the largest group of
Unitarian Christians they were called
the book of meals those dear to gods
over 60,000 when Islam came to them they
accepted this pure monotheism that you
guys are upon worshipping the Creator
not the creation it was amazing you know
throughout time you see this this
oppression and people rewriting history
but I mentioned this point because there
are other people who are stuck out there
not believing that the theology that
doesn't make sense
now based on evidence and proof but when
they hear this that there are Christians
like yourselves who accepted Islam
because you only wanted to worship the
one God and then I bring this point of
Europe the heart of your Bosnia and
learning this history man it's freedom
and that's what I like that
powerful I like I like what I like what
he said the point he said is that
obviously we are sharing this because we
want the best for everybody when we were
when we were in Spain when people from
the Spaniards when they go to their
roots its Islam when you people the
Philippine Philippines that we learned
that a hundred percent of the
Philippines almost were Muslims now it's
about eleven percent is that right
Julian then when you come when you come
to the African American people the Kunta
kinte's when the Malcolm X the Muhammad
Ali when they go back to their roots its
Islam so we want people Christians I
just gave this up example of the
Unitarians there in Bosnia throughout
time when people come to want to go to
their roots the roots of the first man
Adam was Islam submission to the will of
the Creator not the Christian now if
they choose not to go back to the
natural way we still as God Almighty
tells us in the Quran chapter 60 verse 8
God does not forbid you from dealing
justly and in kindness with those who
have not fought you because of your
religion or driven you out of your home
soul I like what you said we do this out
of the love we want people to come back
to their roots to their natural way of
worshipping the crater not the creation
but if they choose to do otherwise hey
we can still be as our brother use of
quoted you know we get to know each
other but at the same time now working
for a common good to make good on earth
not wrecking havoc in the land that's it
yeah we got it we got it we got to get
people on to watch this I want everyone
to watch this film freedom so we have
the director here and we got the to tell
people real quickly why did they call
you to two white Muslims
[Music]
we got people asking about you guys that
and we'll have we'll have Julian's
programs also we have subtitles now we
have the D show Balkans so we got people
asking about the two white Muslims
because they've watched your show with
the subtitles in the Bosnian Croatian
Serbian the Balkan subtitles so now
people people who have heard your story
all the way over there
translated yeah oh so freedom now so we
got now this film that everybody should
watch if they truly want to be free and
liberated from the shackles of the mind
tell us again how can people when is the
event coming up we'll see about our
interviews with known as you watch the
so all this we have a fantastic lineup
of speakers you name it you know so we
12 hours life from a us time Los Angeles
is 8 p.m. and it will be broadcast again
back to back another 12 hours so people
we can catch up with us
the tourism will be our host and the
theme is
Unite's because we just send an email to
a couple of friends my first single was
no more divisions our style of the fight
among religions when I became a scene I
was under the impression that the
Brotherhood will be strong enough to
avoid division and then I realize all
these splits and it's seven years of
frustration for me where people are
boycotting this type of scholar because
he said something ten years ago or five
years ago and I put a basically bashing
each other as one of my favorites
choruses in Canada a bigger fish to fry
I don't have the time to disagree with
you on the 5% me and you will never
agree upon but you and I will be uh 95
let's start to work on the 95 and Allah
will tell us on the day of judgment if
you're right or wrong on the 5% right so
we really want people transcend we don't
have to tie anymore to be divided we
have to try our best to understand each
other and work together you know today I
live in a small city in the UK you know
city there are six masters and the
leaders of those messages and indeed
their congregations don't talk to each
other we've got six messages and they
don't talk to each other that's the case
because we can't even speak to each
other on a local level we need to fix
this and we need to fix this soon
absolutely so any eyes okay we got the
information now people can log in as May
11th freedom
[Music]
that's right so you're French and
they're British with world-class
speakers and the first viewing of the
film freedom it's going to be broadcast
during this conference the conference
starts your time in the morning and goes
then will be repeated again from the 12
hours free with free bike routes N and W
conference calm so that's new Muslim
world
[Music]
free parking record from your laptop
from your from your tablet from your
phone whatever device you choose to
watch this on you can watch this
conference from the comfort of your own
home hamdulillah we look forward to you
joining us on the 11th of May satella
and any thank you so much for allowing
us to come up to your show once again we
very appreciate it
humbly that you're a great man and an
inspiration to all of those things so
humbly thank you guys and we'll see you
guys and freedom may God Almighty Allah
rewards you for all your wonderful work
and for this beautiful film and the
event and I hope to see you all soon
[Music]